i think by now we have a reasonable
sense of what
linear
linear dependence means
so let's just do a slightly more formal
definition of linear dependence so we're
going to say that uh that a set of
vectors let me just define my set of
vectors so let me say let me call my set
s of vectors
v 1
v 2
all the way
to v n
so i'm going to say that they are
linearly dependent
linearly
if and only if so sometimes it's written
if
if with a lot of f's in there so
sometimes it's certain if and only if
sometimes it's shown like an arrow in
two directions
if and only if i can satisfy this
equation i can find a set of constants
i can find a set of constants c1 times
v1 so i can take a linear combination
of my vectors
all the way to cn
vn
that turn that satisfy the equation that
i can create this into the zero vector
so sometimes it's just written as is
bold zero and sometimes you could just
write it i mean we don't know the
dimensionality of this vector you know
it'd be zero it'd be a bunch of zeros we
don't know how how how many actual
elements are in each of these in each of
these vectors but you get the idea so
it's a my set of vectors is linearly
dependent remember i'm saying dependent
not
not independent is linearly dependent if
and only if i can satisfy this equation
for sum
for some
c i's
where not all of them are equal to zero
for some cis we're not all and this is
key not all
are
zero
or you could you could say it the other
way you could say at least one
at least one
is
non-zero
non-zero so how does this gel with what
we were talking about in the previous
video where i said look a set is
linearly dependent if one of the vectors
can be represented by the by the by the
the combination of the other vectors so
let me write that down so we in the last
video i said look you know one vector
one vector
can
be
well let me write it this way
one vector being represented by the sum
of the other vectors i can just write
like this i could write a little bit
more mathy
in the last video i said that linear
dependence means that let me just pick
an arbitrary vector
v1 let's say that v1 is you know i'm
this is arbitrary v1 could be
represented by some combination of the
other vectors
by you know let me call them
a1 times
v let me be careful
a2 times v2 plus a3 times v3
plus all the way up to a n times vn this
is what we said in in the previous video
look if this is literally depend if any
one of these guys can be represented as
some combination of the other ones so
how does this imply that and in order to
show this if and only if i have to show
that this implies that and i have to
show that that implies this so this is
almost a trivially easy proof because if
i if i subtract v1 from both sides of
this equation i get
i get
0 is equal to
-1
v1
plus
a2 v2 plus a3 v3 all the way to a n
vn
and clearly i've just i've just said
well this is lin this is linear
dependent that means that i can
represent this vector as a sum of the
other vectors which means that minus 1
times v 1 plus some combination of the
other vectors is equal to 0
which means that i've been able to
satisfy this equation and at least one
of my constants
is non-zero
non-zero
so i've shown you that if i can
represent one of the vectors by some of
the other ones then this condition is
definitely going to be true now let me
go the other way let me show you if i
have this situation that that i can
definitely represent one of the vectors
as the sum of the others
so let's say that let's say that this is
true
let's say that this is true and one of
the vector and one of these constants
remember it's not just this it's at
least one is non-zero so let me just
assume just for the sake of simplicity i
mean these are all arbitrary let me just
assume
i'll do the new color let me do it in
the magenta
let me assume
that c1 is not equal to zero if c1 is
not equal to zero then i can just divide
both sides of this equation by c1 and
what do i get i get v1
plus c2 over
c1
v2 plus all the way up to cn over c1 is
equal to zero
and then i can multiply both sides of
this by
or i could add negative v1 to both sides
of this equation or subtract v1 from
both sides and i get
c2 over c1 v2
plus all the way up to cn
over
c1 vn this is vn here is equal to minus
v1
is equal to minus v1 now if i just
multiply both sides of this by negative
one i get a minus and all these become
minuses and this becomes a plus
and i just showed you that if at least
one of these constants is non-zero that
i can represent
my vector v1 as some combination of the
other vectors so we're able to go this
way too if this is if this condition is
true then i can represent one of the
vectors as a combination of the others
if i can represent one of the vectors as
a combination of the others then this
condition is true so hopefully that that
kind of proves that these two
definitions are equivalent maybe it's a
little bit of overkill but let's apply
that definition now to actually test you
know you might say hey sal why'd you go
through all of this effort and i went
through all of this effort because this
is actually a really useful
it's a really useful way
to test whether things are linearly
independent or dependent let's try it
out let's use our newly found tool
so let's say i have the set of vectors
let me let's say i have the set of
vectors let me do it up here i want to
be
efficient with my space usage
so let's say i have the set of vectors
2 1
and
3 2.
and my question to you is are these
linearly
independent or are they linearly
dependent
well in order for them to be linearly
dependent that means that there's some
if some constant times 2 1
plus some other constant times this
second vector
3 2
where this should be equal to 0 where
these both aren't necessarily 0. so
let's let me before i go up for this
problem let's remember what we're going
to find out
if either of these are non-zero so if
either
if c1 or c2
non-zero
then this implies that we are dealing
with a dependent linearly dependent
network uh
set
linearly dependent now if c1 and c2 are
both zero
both zero if the only way to satisfy
this equation i mean you can always
satisfy it with by setting everything
equal here but the only way to satisfy
it is by making both of these guys zero
then we're dealing with a linearly
independent set
so let's try to do some math and this
will just take us back to our algebra 1
days
so in order for this to be true that
means 2 times c1
2 times c1
plus 3 times c2 is equal to
when i say this is equal to 0 it's
really the 0 vector so i can rewrite
this as 0 0
so it's equal to so 2 times c 1 plus 3
times c 2 would be equal to that 0 there
and then we'd have 1 times c1
1 times c1 plus 2 times c2
plus 2 times c2 is equal to that 0
is equal to that 0 right there and now
this is just a system two equations two
unknowns a couple of things we could do
let's just multiply
and let's just multiply this top
equation by one half and then so if you
multiply it by one half you get
c one
plus three halves
c two
is equal to
zero
and then
if we subtract the green equation from
the red equation this becomes zero
two minus one and a half three halves is
one and a half so this is just one half
c two is equal to zero
and this is easy to solve c two is equal
to zero
so what's c one let's just substitute
this back in c2 is equal to zero so this
is equal to zero so c1 plus zero is
equal to zero so c1 is also equal to
zero we could have substituted back into
that top equation as well so the only
solution to this equation the only
solution to this equation involves both
c1 and c2 being equal to zero so they
both have to be zero so this is a
linearly
linearly independent set
independent set of vectors which means
that neither of them are redundant of
the other one you can't represent one as
a combination of the other and since we
have two vectors here and they're
linearly independent we can actually
know that this will span r
this will this will span
r2
the span of of my r vectors is equal to
if one of these vectors was just some
multiple of the other then the span
would have been some line within r2 not
all of but now i can represent any
vector in r2 as some combination of
those let's do another let's do another
example
let's say
let me scroll to the right because
sometimes this
this thing when i go too far down i
haven't figured out why
when i go too far down it starts messing
up
so my next example is the set of vectors
so i have the vector
2 1 i have the vector
and i have the vector
2 and i want to know are these linearly
dependent or linearly independent so i
do go through the same drill i use a
little that little that little theorem
that i proved at the beginning of this
video so in order for these to be well
linearly
in sorry in order for them to be
linearly dependent there must be some
set of
weights that i can multiply these guys
so c1 times this vector plus c2
times this vector
plus c3 times
that vector
that will equal
the zero vector
and if one of these is non-zero then
we're dealing with a linearly dependent
set of vectors and if all of them are
zero then it's independent
so let's just do our linear algebra
let's just do our linear algebra well
actually i'll i'll well let me just so
this means that two times c one
two times c one
plus three times c two
plus c3 is equal to that zero up there
and then if we do the bottom rows
remember when you multiply scalar times
the vector you multiply it by each of
these terms so c one times one so
one c one
plus two c 2
plus 2 c 3
is equal to 0.
now there's a couple of giveaways on
this problem if you have three two
dimensional vectors one of them is going
to be redundant because in in the very
best case you know if even if you assume
that let's say that that vector and that
vector are linearly independent then
these would span r two which means that
any point any vector in in your
two-dimensional space can be represented
by some combination of those two
in which case this is going to be one of
them because this is just a vector in
two-dimensional space so it'd be
linearly dependent and then if you say
well these aren't linearly independent
well then if these aren't linearly
independent then these these you know
they're just multiples of each other in
which case this would definitely be a
linearly dependent set so when you when
you see three vectors that are each only
vectors in r2 that are each
two-dimensional vectors it's a complete
giveaway that this is linearly dependent
but i'm going to show it to you
using our
dependent using our our little theorem
here so i'm going to show you that i can
get non-zeros c3 c2s and c1s such that i
can get a zero here if all of these had
to be zero i mean you can always set
them equal to zero but if they had to be
equal zero they would be linearly
independent
but let me just show you look i can just
pick some random c3 let me pick c3
to be equal to negative 1. so what are
these what would these two equations
reduce to i mean if you have three
unknowns and two equations it means you
know you don't have enough constraints
on your system so if i just set c3 i
just picked that out if i had i could
have picked c3 to be anything but if i
set c3 to be equal to negative 1 what
are these
what do these equations become you get 2
c1 plus 3 c2
minus 1 is equal to 0 and you get c1
plus 2 c2
minus 2 is equal to 0 right 2 times -1
and then i can what can i do here if i
multiply this second equation by 2
what do i get i get 2
plus 4
c 2
minus 4
is equal to 0
and now let's subtract this equation
from that equation
so the c1s cancel out three c two minus
four c two is minus
c two and then minus one
minus minus four so that's minus one
plus four that's plus three
is equal to
zero
and so we get our see let me make sure i
got that right
minus
we have a minus one
minus a minus four so plus four so we
have a plus 3 right so that is a
minus 2
so we have our
c 2 is equal so minus c 2 is equal to
minus 3 or c 2 is equal to 3. so we get
c2 is equal to 3. and if c2 is equal to
3 and c3 is equal to minus 1. let's just
substitute here so we get
c1
plus 2 times c2 so plus 6 plus two times
c3 so minus two
minus two is equal to zero
c1 plus four is equal to zero
c1 is equal to minus four
c1 is equal to -4 so i'm giving you a
combination of c's that will give us the
zero vector if i multiply
minus 4 times our first vector 2 1
that's c1
plus
3 times our second vector three two
minus one
minus one times our third vector one two
this should be equal to zero let's
verify it just for fun minus four times
two is minus eight
plus nine
minus one that's yeah minus minus nine
minus plus nine that's zero minus four
times this minus four
plus six
minus two minus four plus six minus two
that's also 0. so we've just shown a
linear combination of these vectors
where actually none of the constants are
zero but all we had to show is that at
least one of the constants had to be
non-zero and we we actually showed all
three of them were but at least one of
these had to be non-zero and these and i
was able to satisfy this equation i was
able to make them into the zero vector
so this shows this proves
that this is a
linearly
linearly dependent
dependent set of vectors linearly
dependent which means one of the vectors
is redundant and you can never just say
oh this is the redundant vector because
i can represent this as a combination of
those two you could just as easily pick
this guy as the redundant vector and say
hey these two i can represent this guy
as a sum of those two there's not kind
of one bad apple in the bunch any of
them can be represented by the
combination of some other by by all of
the rest of them so hopefully uh you
have a better intuition of linear
dependence and independence maybe i'll
continue i'll do a few more examples in
the next video